but first up she is the former editor
and an owner of The Hollywood Reporter
billboard Media Group please welcome
Janice men
[Music]
[Applause]
okay sorry you're a bit of a newsmaker
yourself because you know The Hollywood
Reporter right was the were the ones who
were on this story with Harvey Weinstein
before anybody else and it was hard to
it's hard to land that whale on the
shore wasn't it was uh it was really
hard I have to tell you Harvey Weinstein
has loomed over me for seven years the
whole time I have done The Hollywood
Reporter and one of literally loomed oh
yes he you know one of the first
conversations I ever had I had hired a
reporter named Kim masters who is the
first person I've ever heard and the
first conversation we had she told me
about a conversation she had had with
Harvey Weinstein and it was off the
record but I'll tell you what she asked
him and she said Harvey well he he said
he said to her you know what do you want
to know and she said I heard you rape
women what do you have to say about that
and so there are two publicists in the
room with them who are sort of like
homina homina and and so from that point
on because I knew what his answer was
that we really put an effort put a lot
of effort towards trying to what was his
answer I can't say it was an
off-the-record conversation but it
didn't
it definitely didn't didn't make me
doubt right all the smoke that was in
the air but it is funny that in this age
were nothing nothing we can agree on the
one thing that is bipartisan is treating
women like this right yes I mean that
liberals do it it could serve you I mean
the Liberals get caught the
Conservatives get caught do you see is
there any pattern you see differently
with like between liberals and
conservatives on this or how their
communities react to it I mean I think
the only pattern we see is that is how
prevalent it is and how there are walls
of secrecy around around these cases of
abuse everywhere whether it's Penn State
whether it's the Catholic Church right
whether it's you know the White House
politics that these things have there's
always a they're always people covering
up for them or or in a yes and I've you
know I've heard the Conservatives say
you know it took a village to help you
know Harvey wants it but it's also took
a village to elect the other sex
predator well I had lunch today with two
two prominent women in Hollywood who
said that has actually been a welcome
relief to talk about Harvey Weinstein
this week instead of Donald Trump for
once but you know I have this theory
that I think it's all just sublimated
anger towards Donald Trump its whole
feeding friends if you you know it's
with a one-year anniversary of the
Access Hollywood tapes and you know he
gets elected and this guy there is some
possible tangible crime and punishment
that will happen now
what do you think conservatives of also
said this week that you know those of us
who left at Mike Pence were following
the Billy Graham rule if you're not
familiar with the Billy great probably
many of you are practicing it right now
it's if you're married you never have
like a meal or a drink with a single
woman and I think when you go to any
place where that serves alcohol you
bring you bring your wife because right
the chicks could get out of control and
what they say well if that would you
know if the liberals had practice that
and then our
you know the woman wouldn't be in the
situation with Harvey ones he doesn't
quite make sense let's remember this is
a man who calls his wife mommy or mother
or whatever's going under he doesn't
have like pence wins Harvey I don't
think he did that but the the one for
her I mean it's sort of I mean Harvey
Weinstein is just emblematic of this
whole larger issue that we we have not
been able to solve and and hopefully
this makes that conversation happen more
of women not being treated equally not
being in positions of power and I think
this whole thing has made me feel in the
last week I knew this was going on in
Hollywood but not to this extent and you
feel like you know if you're on your
iPhone or your phone like every 30
minutes a news alert comes out and about
someone else that was it reminds me a
little a member in the 90s my dear old
friends still my friend Roseanne yes
talked about child molestation right and
I don't think it and I but I remember
everybody been like wow she's
exaggerating right of course we know it
exists but it's not widespread like
she's saying sure that she was right
right and we found it it is kind of
really widespread way more than my it's
so mind-boggling and I you know I
remember when I first learned about
campus rape for example and I remember
thinking oh that it could never be that
pervasive who wants to have sex with a
comatose woman like that's like how
weird do you have to be like there are
not enough it must be more about power
like isn't it easier to they should
teach a course in health class in school
like how to be attractive to a woman
right
even Harvey Weinstein who is ugly
[Laughter]
ugly men can be Humphrey Bogart was not
good-looking correct
you could harvey weinstein could have
lost 135 thousand pounds
like just look groomed dress fly hmm be
considerate great like actually be
interested there is a way harvey you
actually could have gotten a woman to go
to bed with you willingly i don't
understand why that wouldn't have been
so much that was a Riley you know it's
always but this you know it's it's it's
more power don't you say it is 100%
about power but you know Harvey is not
he was not just a sexual offender he was
also physically assaulting men and he
was known for you know he punched his
brother in the nose broke his nose he
was known in meetings to throw things at
people and if you ever meet people who
worked at The Weinstein Company or
Miramax Harvey's companies there is a
palpable PTSD around them where you know
they make this joke with him oh are you
in a hurry survivors group and it's not
funny you know and say they are really
stricken but the amazing thing about
about the secrecy that goes around
sexual assault you they would tell you
funny stories funny stories about you
know his temper and freak outs and bad
behavior but no one no one in seven
years would ever go on the record and
say he sexually assaulted someone and I
think you know what I kept thinking is
if it's just like this in Hollywood with
rich famous people right when do we get
to the poor people women in the country
that's you know I think about some
here were working at the Tyson food
plant chopping heads off chickens on a
conveyor belt all day for $10 an hour
and the shift boss you know is like
hinting he wants a bar job or I could
hire somebody else
what is that poor woman well okay I mean
I think you know this is also made me
think this week about I mean we this is
a country that since 1923 has been
unable to pass an Equal Rights Amendment
that we are that we you know we believe
we say and you grew up thinking that
women are treated equally and then but
no one is able to legislate that because
people I think too many people at heart
don't want it are not comfortable with
it and it's a basic just we're basically
fundamentally saying women should be
paid the same should have equal rights
and we can't even as a country agree on
that so what do you you see how that
trickles down to workplace harassment
the ability to have recourse the ability
to go to HR department and not have not
think that at HR departments not going
straight to Roger Ailes and asking Roger
Ailes how to fix it and you've seen that
you saw that happen at The Weinstein
Company
you know you feel I think if you're a
victim of sexual harassment or assault
you feel trapped we're also losing our
ability to talk about things right
I mean SNL didn't do Harvey Weinstein
jokes and got [ __ ] about it right and
then James Corden did some he got [ __ ]
about it so which is it
and aren't publicist telling their
clients like just it's a terrible State
for America to be in about any issue
just in general like we are just too
afraid to talk about
I mean I feel like we're a little bit in
like Robespierre French Revolution times
I'm saying every week the purity police
well be and and I'll give you two
examples this week that I thought were
really unfortunate one of them was Ben
Affleck who released a really nice
statement about about supporting the
women and and there was an unfortunate
very inappropriate incident he did
twelve years ago I believe it wasn't on
MTV's TRL where he grabbed a woman's
breasts I think under no circumstance
does anyone thinks that was a good thing
but it is do you think Ben Affleck's
will ever talk about this topic again
never in a million years I'm assuming
event another incident
Molly Ringwald the actress who a lot of
us grew up with she wrote a piece in The
New Yorker about why she left Hollywood
moved to Paris and a lot of it involved
sexual assault and harassment you know
including when she was the age of 13
some crew member asking her to dance and
he had an erection I mean it was just
you know really creepy stuff but in that
story it referenced an incident when she
quit Hollywood it's a pickup quote of a
pickup quote like a movie line the
publication that didn't exist the picked
up a quote that Esquire thought was real
it may have might have even been real
from Jeffrey Katzenberg who I'm sure you
know a big executive here in town one of
the legends here and he was attributed
with saying this quote at the time when
Molly Ringwald left I wouldn't I
wouldn't even know who she was if she
sat on my face okay so so Jeffrey
Katzenberg who does not I have never
known I've never known to speak like
that ever right yes right I can't
imagine he's not that funny
no he just and so he is in this position
of suddenly issuing an apology for
tomorrow manager for something he
doesn't even he's not even sure he said
but this you know he had stuck his neck
out earlier he released the email he
wrote to Harvey Weinstein after Harvey
Weinstein asked him after the New York
Times story came out looking for support
and all of a sudden Jeff Jeffrey is like
in his position of oh my god do I win
you're talking about this topic Liberals
have to stop losing their shut down calm
down
ya know who the enemy is and embrace
each other thank you so much with me on
that
[Applause]